we're learning another American has
died fighting in Ukraine the U.S Navy
confirmed former Navy SEAL Daniel
Swift was killed during a Russian
attack in eastern Ukraine this week also
this week president zielinski repeated
urgent pleas for allies meeting in Germany
Friday to immediately send Modern tanks to help
Ukrainian forces prepare for looming Russian
attacks Deborah patta has more from kharkiv
that meeting of Western allies
in Germany did not bring the news
that Kev was hoping for there's still no
final decision on the rapid deployment of
German tanks for Ukraine and the U.S has
signaled that this war is far from over
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff did not
mince his words I still maintain that for this
year it would be very very difficult to militarily
eject the Russian forces from all every inch of
Ukrainian occupied or Russian occupied Ukraine but
General Mark merely emphasized that with the right
weapons and training Ukraine can still launch a
widespread counter-offensive in Spring and the
U.S will designate the Russian paramilitary group
Wagner as a transnational criminal organization
releasing satellite images said to show the group
receiving a shipment of Arms from North Korea
on the Ukrainian Front Line the men of the bugans
Special Forces Brigade refused to give up hope
believing they can win as long as the West keeps
sending them weapons but for all the promises of
high-tech Firepower there is no shortcut when
it comes to digging in against the enemy is
it difficult to build trenches when the ground
is Frozen it's very hard major chicken told us
it's rock solid ice with constant rain and snow
this is trench warfare 14 Sub-Zero temperatures
and there's a lot of territory to defend this one
is just near the Russian border the commander and
his platoon have been fighting in the country's
East where Ukrainian soldiers are preparing to
defend against a surge in Russian attacks deep
below this innocuous looking Pine Forest is a
warrant of fortifications it's very warm in here
where the men have prepared for the coldest weeks
of winter a Wood-Fired stove warm beds hot food
and drinks it's not so bad chicken told us but
what would really make a difference are more
heavy weapons that will stop the Bloodshed on
the battlefield sooner president zielinski said
his country needs tanks not hundreds of thank
yous and he told that meeting in Germany time
remains a Russian weapon and that the waste
needs to speed up the delivery of military aid for
CBS Saturday morning Deborah patter heart Keith